[Music]
thank you
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
foreign
biggest Meg anyone's ever seen
everybody back into the station
three massive exit who knows what else
have escaped the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I don't know
[Applause]
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
we can relax this place is magproof when
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
[Music]
barracuda
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
two
enjoy the show
what happens in there
fueled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
[Music]
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
[Music]
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
everything is about winning
it's the things we love most
Australians
killed Danvers prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I don't
know cold No Air
space
[Applause]
[Music]
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
[Music]
laughs
what is happening to me
[Music]
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
strong Theory
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
foreign
[Music]
targeting every planet we call home
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
faster
assistant
[Music]
I can't can you I got it
you've been fighting the Hurricanes for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
my father didn't believe in Revenge
we believe in from it
let me fight beside you
he said I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him
I'm fighting for my people
[Music]
you young pop
do you believe in Paul
there are signs
the prophet why is that a bad thing use
it because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paul the trades are still alive
foreign
deal with this prophet
[Music]
show me who you are
your father
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
no do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
all right
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
Oh My Demons
[Music]
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
[Music]
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Splinter some
other guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to tuck him out of it yeah you
ratted us out hey don't use that word
that way I mean it's 20 25
. hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
this is insane
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen a space why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
oh my God
When The War started
they've protected me
took better care of me than humans sort
of
and our people Maya
this programming
ten years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
clear Warhead in Los Angeles
this is a fight for our very existence
we are this close to winning the war
but the AI are developing a super weapon
retrieve it
they went
[Music]
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a kid
no you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven so we're just saying we can't go
to heaven because you're not good
and I'm not a person
you're gonna do other things she looks
like a little girl now but she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
who said you want me
what do you want sweetie are robots to
be free
oh we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
my son never show Mercy we
are predators
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind you know my
business yes
power is about strength
if you show weakness you will give our
enemies an opening
[Applause]
shot
thank you
he is weak like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me
I have a connection with animals to
track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off it's six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you have some kind of Honor we
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting foreign
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
your goddamn lunatic oh you just figured
that out now
foreign
don't you want to know why they call me
the rhino
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
I'm Gonna Fly oh let's do this
yeah
you got a force it to come out what do
you you're a genius I know like what I
say
oh did you know what was going to happen
to my brother when you stuck him with
this world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to untrust me
[Music]
post acquired who said that systems
oh no
hey eliminated
you think the government is going to do
when they figure out that some kid has
this military attack
it belongs to me
yeah that's more like it
low you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong for him that's what
makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
sorry my mama
our hero Cumberland
you're the boom anal that could use that
Arsenal right about now God can never
ask oh yeah
me back away
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
foreign
human here I'm nobody I ain't even seen
nothing I'm not even seeing anything
right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
foreign
[Music]
yeah baby
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever wow
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
he's lying to you and I think you know
it
[Music]
miles want to get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy dangerous this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's the guy got to do to join
this spider team you can never be part
of this don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999.99
go easy on the kid he had a terrible
teacher Peter files you have a baby
I'll take it from here
from here being Spider-Man is a
sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every word
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
can't stop me now you can't run forever
dude I can't lose one more friend
ly
he's telling me how my story is supposed
to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and then I looked at my uh let me guess
he died
this is Bella
Bella this is Mr McCandless hello fella
[Music]
she's an experiment good evening and
rainy and her body are not quite
synchronized
but she is progressing at an accelerated
piece
[Music]
tell me where did she come from
or it is a happy tail
[Music]
and there was a world to enjoy so I can
navigate it is the goal of all to
progress grow a woman plotting her
course to Freedom
[Music]
oh
I've been having it
the strangest dreams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
[Music]
we're delighted to let you know that
we've had in on our wait list
we got a spot at the womb Center oh my
God but I haven't told Alvey yet oh why
Rachel
[Music]
he wants a natural child
but hold on you put us on a wait list to
have a baby in the name no it's not an
egg it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you let's do it Rachel
really yeah
parents are raving about it it is the
ultra solution
my nephew was born at the womb Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
[Music]
I can't do it with a pot in here what
are you talking about it can't see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not
maybe I'm just not ready to be a mother
you know no one's a mother just like
that you become one
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry it's not possible I won't
raise this child without nature
congratulations it's so exciting isn't
it
I noticed a change in productivity you
do have a baby at the womb center right
why
[Music]
things are revolving your family
Dynamics are about to undergo true
nanda's changes
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
bored babies
thank you
[Music]
something isn't right
I don't know what's going on
I need to find a way back yes
what to wear
what can you tell us about this wizard I
could take you to his castle beyond that
you're the one's intent I'm dying to run
run
an angel come to save us all
never seen anyone fight like that
you're a Wanderer
we have to kill them before they kill us
the only way to stop their Invasion
catch you said you wanted to prove
yourself this is the time
evil is as Unstoppable as the rain fired
that's why we fight for those that can't
a good man knows that the darkness will
always be there and stands against it
anyway
[Music]
all right
where on Earth are we not earth
world
I think that we ought to change our
Town's slogan great place to call home
is confusing I suggest a great place to
refer to is home we need a crosswalk on
Trent Avenue between Frost and Allegheny
and also
oh my our UFO has crashed my backyard
has taken out my azaleas and destroyed
my bird bath and you talk like that it
makes them all take us less seriously
did you just say UFO
what is that you remember the spaceship
this is the little man who came out of
it he's got to be a secret don't tell
anybody
she shouldn't know we gotta trust her
there's nothing else we can do you can
kill her kill me
you can't kill me I'll kill you that's
what I'll do stop it you think we can
call them Jewels he's not Jules he's
more of a Gary your dad was in here
earlier he said he was buying apples for
an alien like an illegal alien thank you
for the picture he hands them to me all
the time maybe he's trying to tell you
something dad come on I'm worried what
you have said has not been normal I'm
okay how can you say that when you're
buying apples for an alien
the government is searching for a
security satellite that crashed any
moment we waste is a moment they can
discover him you've seen the movies you
know what happens to the these guys when
they fold it hurt
[Music]
s
Jules has come to mean quite a bit to us
it's about Dad buying apples for an
alien
they're coming
last four hanging out together we got
along pretty well we're so thankful for
you
yeah you got me
[Music]
what the
most people with abilities I detect
young at five or six maybe we can start
with a name
Aurora
[Applause]
[Music]
not like normal people around
these abilities only work of you are in
control
[Music]
so what's his name
whose name we're not playing that game
you want to keep secrets and she'll be
better in your mind how about you stand
on my head and give me some privacy
I ask you about your abilities I like to
do projections you say you hate what we
read and yet you love that garbage
that's good can you move objects I'm not
good at it you need a teacher Rob
the abilities they're complicated
they're transformative
they can be dangerous underneath let's
go come on I'm not going with you
I need you to start telling me the truth
no more lies just trying to give you the
tools to protect yourself who
a
this is
quite funny
join us
oh she's freaking out
three new ones
you know you really captured his Essence
maybe his face could use a lot more
detail though
it's like a photograph
I'm Adam Chloe
[Music]
sure you're not gonna make fun of me
all right
oh my God
this might be the nicest thing anyone's
ever done for me
[Music]
they don't have love in their culture
they find romantic stuff super exotic
and interesting
they watch you'll go on dates
family dinner is one of our most
cherished human rituals do you have to
do this right now Chloe you're not
supposed to talk about the podcast on
the broadcast
[Music]
hey would you keep that out of my
line of sight why don't you keep your
out of our line of sight you didn't
invent courtship broadcast
it has recently become obvious you are
deceiving your viewers what deceiving
the title of your broadcast is Adam and
Chloe in love and yet you are not in
love
I want you to repay all funds you have
received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
and your families will be in debt
sex Generations
oh
do you want me to cut that for you
where is the nearest restaurant
no part of my body can make that noise
well it certainly won't if you don't try
the romantic love is the most poetic of
all human love notes it should never be
faked
I'm just like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my feet
we've lost a lot since you guys came
here
but we've overcome a lot too
foreign
[Music]